all right cj watson is a former nba
player turned entrepreneur jc talked to
him about his latest project
take a look cj watson is a las vegas
native he played in the nba for 10 years
and he just released
his third children's book welcome back
to the show cj how you doing buddy
doing good how are you thanks for having
me well first off we've got cj's big
dream
cj's big project and now cj's big moment
what is the theme of your children's
books uh well the last one the third one
that just
came out cj's big moment uh it's about
bullying and uh just
showing kids how to handle bullying in a
positive manner uh i want to promote uh
we don't want to promote violence want
to pro positivity and uh just
kind of handling things in a positive
manner so are the books based on your
life we're talking about cj here
are the books based on your childhood
were you bullied as a kid
i wasn't bullying here but i had a
couple of bullied uh stories i can tell
but this is definitely a true story
all these stories are definitely things
that happened in my life and i just want
to tell my story through books
now speaking of children you you're a
new father so so congratulations
how has becoming a dad changed your
world
uh for the third time i think it's uh i
think i'm getting better the third time
around um
just staying up late uh changing diapers
uh now
back to bottles and diapers and things
of that nature so it's just uh it's
always fun just to bring another
another human to this world and uh just
trying to make our uh the best that we
can
now talking about children's books uh
growing up did you have a favorite that
maybe your parents read to you every
night or was that go-to kid's book that
you read and if so what was it
uh it's probably like the dr seuss books
i love those uh all those books
i think my favorite was like probably
like uh green eggs and ham um just i
always loved those themes in the books
that kind of made me smile as a kid
maybe be creative maybe think and wonder
and
and kind of dream so i think reading as
a kid helped me be an author
i love it because is that that's what
you're doing for kids now making them
think and
dream and my last question for you
you've been on the show many times i
always wanted to ask you this about your
nba career
you played for the golden state warriors
the bulls the nets the pacers and
orlando magic
do you have a favorite team uh i think
i would say the bulls is my favorite
team i would say all of them actually
because they all gave me a shot
and uh but i would say that the first
team the lawyers they gave me my first
legitimate shot in the nba to
kind of make that dream come true and
kind of hold my basketball skills and
they kind of developed me as a player so
i would say the warriors is my favorite
team because i gave you my first start
cj or las vegas native and we love you
so much thanks for joining the show
we get your books on amazon thank you so
much my friend
thank you thanks for having me
appreciate it you can get all of cj
watson's books including his latest cj's
big moment on amazon